what was the change like for barber
shops
in the early stages of the pandemic the
first couple of months
versus now where people are reopening
and they're allowed to have people into
their barber shops uh but still people
are cautious
yeah first few months were frightening
for everyone particularly uh
our customers um they were pretty
abruptly forced to shut down in most
states
and you know they're not like a lot of
uh
you know collar workers that can just
work from home and have that luxury yeah
they need to be in the shop
cutting in order to provide for the
families so it was very very difficult
and challenging
uh march april um we saw almost all of
our shops
shut down completely um during during
that during that time
um what's that like for you then do you
then give them a pause on charging them
for software or a discount or something
how do you handle that for yourself
yeah great great question so we early on
we made some really strategic decisions
and
we held it up with our leadership team
and we decided that
we were going to wave all subscription
fees across the board for all
current and new customers we decided
at the time to waive it until september
and then we actually decided to extend
it until 2021
um and wow yeah so no revenue for you
for the
during the 2020 pandemic year well no
subscription revenue so we didn't really
get into our revenue model but we
actually
make revenue from payment processing and
from some other uh
streams as well um but subscription
revenue
we uh we decided and that is the most
direct uh
you know source of revenue that's felt
by the the shop owners
got it yeah so if they're where they pay
five percent or ten percent
to pay for fees associated with the
credit card
no they they pay standard um you know
2.9 plus 30 give or take
uh you know that you would you would
find with other you know similar
companies
um and then we have a we have a portion
of our revenue that is the
booking fee that the actual client the
person getting the haircut pays
ah yeah yeah should they pay a dollar or
two bucks to book the
exactly when they book and pay so if
your book if you opt into booking and
paying kind of like that uber experience
where you're just in and out don't have
to worry about cash
and you'll pay a slight premium for it
and then if you
decide to book without paying in that
case you wouldn't you wouldn't
you wouldn't pay anything extra and do
you build individual apps for each
barber shop or do you have like a
central barbershop app for
people to use to aggregate demand we
have both
we have what we call a square flagship
app which
has all the barbershops that are on
squier on it
and then we also do custom branded apps
um and
in that case it's the basic
functionality is the same but we
customize it to have the look and feel
of the shop so it feels like an
extension of their brand and it doesn't
it doesn't say squire anywhere on there
of the thousand people using the
platform how many are back to work in
october of 2020.
fortunately um overwhelming majority are
open back up
and and not many have shut down for good
which was
which is really good because that's what
we're concerned about um that some shops
just wouldn't be able to sustain
themselves
but you know barbershops are very very a
resilient businesses
and they typically do very well in
economic downturns
nobody thought about a pandemic
happening that's probably the only
circumstance that
caused them to close the doors but
fortunately we're seeing them
reopening bouncing back now the revenue
is starting to normalize
uh on a per shot basis so you know it's
not quite where it was
pre-covered but um their their clients
are still coming in
in aggregate uh 60 70 80
90 what's what's the average barbershop
doing now compared to what they did
last year without covid yeah i would say
on average probably around 85 to 90
um that's amazing there's some outliers
california for example was shut down
much
longer and so there they've just you
know recently reopened
um but you know some states not for
nancy pelosi she got to go
she might have been a set up but i
wasn't a barber shop so i'll stay right
here